hello folks I'm multi-brand asiak and
this is top five here we countdown the
best and worst performances of our most
beloved actors today we finish up what
we started last week and conclude the
top ten best Robin Williams performances
with his five greatest roles as stated
last week I decided to do a top 10 best
of mr. Williams so if you want to see 10
through 6 go back and check out last
week's video I know a few of you still
might want to see what my top 5 worst
Robin Williams performances were so if
you're interested follow me on twitter
at awesome underscore walter and i'll
make a post about it on there soon it's
been a little over two years since Robin
passed away and that wound is still
pretty fresh for a lot of people I think
it's important that we remember what a
truly unique talent he was so let's
finish off this super-sized list these
are the top five best performances from
Robin Williams number five John Keating
in Dead Poets Society people love this
role from Robin Williams that seize the
day speech is still an all-time cinema
highlight carpe diem English teacher
John Keating just started his new job at
an all-boys prep school the students are
always under very heavy pressure from
the school and their parents to live up
to extremely high standards
Keating's unique teaching approach
inspires the students but upsets their
parents and his peers
regardless Keating's classes encourage
his pupils to pursue their dreams and
seize the day Williams goes full-on
inspirational here it's one of the roles
he's most remembered for and it created
some very iconic quotes I'll admit I
didn't see this until recently and was
actually let down a bit from the movie
I guess it's difficult for me to relate
to a bunch of rich kids in prep school
however Williams absolutely lived up to
the hype I can't why not
I can't talk to him this way and you're
acting for him too you're playing the
part of the dutiful son I know this
sounds impossible but you have to talk
to him you have to show him who you are
what your heart is how he motivates his
students is infectious and his character
has just the right amount of mystery
surrounding him he wants the best for
these kids and sometimes that comes in
conflict with what their parents
envision for them
Thank You boys
thank you seize the day indeed thank you
for this lesson mr. Williams number four
Perry in the Fisher King Robin was known
for his off-the-wall characters and
personality but I never saw anything
like his performance in the Fisher King
shock jock Jack Lucas was a rising star
that turned to alcohol after
inadvertently pushing a caller into
shooting up a local bar and killing a
group of innocent people at his lowest
moment Jack meets Perry a mentally
scarred homeless man who was present as
his wife was murdered by the caller
Jack accidentally encouraged feeling
extreme guilt Jack vows to help Perry
get back on his feet however this is
much easier said than done this terry
gilliam directed movie was guaranteed to
be a little weird but adding Williams in
brought it to a whole nother level in a
good way of course Robin really got
immersed in this character it's him
acting zany but it's very different from
what we've come to expect from him the
way he talks is different the way he
moves is different it's all exclusive to
this character I love this guy
oh you haven't jaded city.we Milotic
he cares Oh jack and this jaded
motherfuckin city that you you will you
shut up you sympathize with Perry very
much in this film and there is a lot
behind his broken psyche there are a lot
of layers for Robin to play with and you
can tell he was having a ball diving
through all of them his chemistry with
Jeff Bridges is something to see as well
those scenes range from funny to
confusing two very heartfelt he turned
to the full moon silvered amazement how
could you find that which my brightest
and bravest could not fool replied I
don't know
I only knew that you were thirsty also
his scenes with amanda plummer who plays
Lydia Sinclair our enjoyably peculiar
one of them leads to a visually stunning
scene let me have this Williams got to
show off even more of his talent in this
film in a way we hadn't seen yet I
strongly suggest checking this one out
if you haven't seen it yet number three
Daniel Hillard in mrs. Doubtfire another
signature Robin Williams role we see him
create something special in mrs.
Doubtfire
Daniel Hillard is a voice actor with a
troubled marriage that ends when his
wife Miranda asks for a divorce she has
granted custody of their three children
with Daniel receiving limited visiting
rights however that's not nearly enough
time together for Daniel or his kids as
Miranda searches for a housekeeper
Daniel decides to disguise himself as an
old Scottish woman named mrs. Doubtfire
she gets the job and once again Daniel
is with his family for most of the day
however Daniel struggles to keep up the
charade as Miranda begins dating James
Bond
since Williams is playing an actor in
this he really got to show off a lot of
fun voices that are still hilarious pa
pa pa pa pa pa pip
piss off loo Nancy and I are still
looking for the other half of my head
gotta go online don't make me smack
Ashley hard I'll do it you know I do a
great impression of a hot dog the main
reason why this is here is of course
because of the mrs. Doubtfire character
he really pulls off embodying a
completely different person from the
voice to her physicality mrs. Doubtfire
becomes independent of the Daniel
character and you almost forget its
blooms under the makeup at a few points
Hey
mrs. Hillard I presume yes I'm Miranda
Hillard
euphegenia doubtfire oh yes won't you
please come in thank you dear
now balancing all that with trying to
keep up the facade creates a few
situations that had to be difficult for
Williams to properly play there's a mrs.
Sellner here the dear
oh she here yes here she is I'm mrs.
Oona I just got out of the shower I
think you'll be very pleased with me
I've been through some really
interesting changes the heart is there
once again as Williams does all this
just to be able to see his kids the love
between them is very believable and we
see the sincerity in his eyes when
Daniel speaks of them I'm addicted to my
children say I love them with all my
heart the idea of someone telling me I
can't be with him I can't see them every
day it's like someone saying I can't
have air I can't live without air and I
I can't live without them also the
speech at the end delivered by mrs.
Doubtfire still feels very earnest and
warm it's a great lesson to take away
from this bill but if there's love dear
those are the ties that bind if you have
a family in your heart whatever
all my love to you puppet you're going
to be alright
people remember mrs. Doubtfire and that
lasting character help it reach number
three on this list however it's not
quite Williams at his peak number two
Shawn Maguire and Good Will Hunting I
spoke about this movie when covering Ben
Affleck's best performances but I think
even more than Damon Williams is the one
that you remember most from this film
will hunting as a young man with an
extremely high IQ however he's never
seen the point in achieving his immense
potential or putting his mind to good
use
he's challenged to do so by MIT
professor Gerald Lambeau and his friend
therapist Shawn Maguire when even his
best friend Chucky starts to question
why hunting works manual labor jobs
instead of using his brain to have a
better life will must decide what's best
for him as a crossroads presents itself
now what elevates this inspirational
character above mr. Keating from Dead
Poets Society is just how much more
relatable Shawn is he's just a regular
guy from Boston who speaks the truth
harsh when necessary loving when needed
and we see Shawn go through his own arc
in this film learning something new from
well while opening up old wounds from
his friendship with Jerry very good shit
that's why I don't come to the goddamn
reunions cuz I can't stand that look in
your eye you know that condescending
embarrassed look you think I'm a failure
I Know Who I am and I'm proud of what I
do it was a conscious choice I didn't
fuck up shawn has a ton of baggage going
into his sessions with will with his
wife dead sean has given up on certain
aspects of his life
however when discussing his wife you see
Williams glow and deliver some
impressively authentic dialogue oh yeah
but will she's been dead two years and
that's the shit I remember wonderful
stuff you know little things like that
happen those are the things I miss the
most the little idiosyncrasies that only
I know about that's what made her my
wife the moment most people point to you
in this movie is the famous bench scene
this is probably my favorite individual
scene Williams ever did doing often
right
do you think I know the first thing
about how hard your life has been how
you feel who you are because I've had
all of the twist does that encapsulate
you I really like this movie and love
Williams in it want to see Robin and his
most inspirational watch Good Will
Hunting now if you'll excuse me I got to
go see about a girl bitch stole my and
the number one best Robin Williams
performance is Sai perish in one hour
photo I was really debating putting this
at the number one spot why do you think
it's his best performance I prefer to
remember Robin Moore as Shawn from Good
Will Hunting or brighter characters than
a dark character like psy but I can't
lie this was Williams at his best
unrecognizable deeply flawed with a mix
of sad and dark motivations this
character did a lot of bad things but
you can't help but feel sorry for sy
Parrish works behind the counter at the
local Save Mart he's a friendly and
personable worker who pleasantly
interacts with his regular customers
however behind the soft blue eyes of sy
is a desperately lonely man who builds
an obsession with the Yorkin family
longtime customers of his who he
imagines as the ideal family when sy
finds out things aren't as perfect as
they seem with the organs he takes his
obsession to even more dangerous levels
it's a true testament to Williams
ability to make a character like this as
sympathetic as he turned out what does a
scarred childhood and years of
loneliness do to someone how and in what
way to those experiences affect that
person important questions Williams goes
headfirst into those dark areas of the
mind without looking back
[Music]
the side character wants a family but
his life is turned out in a way that
leaves him in a very lonely state of
mind where all he has is his job and the
pictures he develops for that job the
narrations are also very strong in this
film science philosophy about pictures
is very fascinating and if these
pictures have anything important to say
to future generations it's this I was
here I existed I was young I was happy
and someone cared enough about me in
this world to take my picture
I should talk a bit about the visuals in
one our photo the director Mark Romanek
has only directed three films he's
usually a music video director his
attention to visual detail as displayed
in beautiful symmetric combined with the
dreamlike haze of sameness occasionally
accompanied by some disturbing images
that create a very unique look sighs
eventually tracked down by shield and we
get a climax that fits in with the movie
but goes very heavy for the shock value
I could have done without that last part
but it doesn't change my opinion of
Liam's performance it's a haunting
portrayal of a scarred person who is
very different on the inside compared to
what his appearance suggests I want to
hear what you guys think what is your
favorite Robin Williams movie or
performance what do you want me to cover
next in the show leave a comment and let
me know follow me on Twitter at awesome
underscore Walter to take part in more
polls about who I may cover in the
future all right guys I just wanted to
talk to you without a script really
quick this is just me talking Robin
Williams was a really special and
different performer and the reason this
took me so long to get through is just
because I was so I hate to use the word
but I was pretty devastated when he died
especially how he died and everything
that happened at the end there so
this was a pretty cathartic for me to go
back and watch his movies I haven't been
able to I just haven't been able to
watch hook especially for whatever
reason really gets to me but hook and
Jumanji and all those movies that I grew
up with mrs. Doubtfire and everything
really were a staple of my childhood
when I was younger and Aladdin of course
and I just couldn't I couldn't watch
those for a long time and it's really
difficult to think about because it's
like we we never knew Robin Williams you
know most of us never met the guy this
is a very difficult thing to think about
because it's like what do we connect
with with him it's it's the emotions
it's a shared experience it's that he
made us laugh for so long in so many
different ways or he made it feel sad
he made us made us feel emotion and I
think that is the goal of any actor or
any entertainers you want to have a
shared experience with someone and Robin
Williams wasn't like my favorite actor
ever but I appreciate him so much and I
and now that he's gone it's just
something that you look back on and it's
like you feel like you knew him and I
didn't know him obviously none of us did
really but that's powerful and I think
that is important and I think that
that's something that you know any actor
or entertainer like I said should strive
towards so going to miss Robin Williams
this is sort of my goodbye to him so um
thank you for watching everybody this is
a difficult episode to do but got
through it and I know a lot of people
are feeling those same emotions so um to
live to leave will be an awfully big
adventure
[Music]
[Applause]
you